my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face and then 11k people
watched the cinemasins video and
download philosophy over cinema says
it's always smile happy face positivity
we got recommended this video by quite a
few people and we don't really cover
cinemasins videos but it's freakin Joker
so we said yes we're definitely gonna do
it the 11 Oscar nominations we wait to
see which ones it takes home in just a
few days clean sweep all of them Lord of
the Rings if you haven't done so already
we would love it if you could go check
out our patreon page weekly Q&A s and TV
show reaction stream alongs meaning you
sync up with a timecode and those shows
are Gotham stranger things season 3 Ages
of shield Cobra Kai season 2 haunting a
hill house season 1 some other shows as
well and then there are shows where we
have the stream along option but
reaction highlights included for them as
well it's like when you see YouTube cuts
for TV shows we do ourselves and those
shows are supernatural Hunter hunter my
hero academia movie included Death Note
Code Geass Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan and one
punch man he does music video reactions
weekly go over to our patreon page and a
would really appreciate that let's do
this tell me if you want me to write one
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it should be information Amanda stories
is finding out only because he read a
letter not intended for him I was about
to say something about tell ya thank you
[Music]
[Music]
mostly about the garbage strike and the
super rats now suddenly Gotham is a
powder keg for assembly shooting really
doesn't we pour at all how does it it
became a spark and some sort of Gotham
class Revolution is occurred by the
movie at all Tomica by Wayne Street
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you know they're awesome just like yeah
I benefit at all yeah I kind of
appreciated the clarity I was annoyed
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so there was apartment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
freeze up like crunch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
switch seats
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we need to devote some time to that Matt
Damon yeah it is good well okay
[Music]
swing-away Merrill Neto fini - well I
like this cinemasins video I quite
enjoyed it this is really fun to watch
and you know scores cinema since II know
sometimes we're just cracking jokes and
they give them a pointless sin sometimes
they're just really nitpicking but there
are times where I thought they brought
up some really great observations and
some really great points especially in
terms of convenience on a lot of things
so for the most part I don't agree with
a lot of this but there were things that
I think are worthy of talking about and
because it's in admissions I decided to
write down like a whole but you can't
see my canvas I don't know bunch of
numbers of like oh yeah I might want to
talk about that through that's the first
one the eleven eleven thing this is the
first time I've ever heard of this did
not even notice I'm saying anxious shy
stress conflicted scattered and that
this clock motif is everywhere in the
movie when examining that as a little
hint or clue playing into how this could
all be in his head I feel like the
production design of that other than
that mode they pointed out on the talk
show with that not reading eleven eleven
well he's no longer these qualities by
that changed but there's a point to be
had there because they're showing a
level emanate here they cut to a point
where he's banging his head and it says
eleven eleven on that clock so it could
be a little bit more of a heavier
implication that this is all just going
on in his head and that's why the time
is kind of the same every time you check
in with it which I thought was neat yeah
the less is sin than just like a neat
piece yeah that's a good analysis but
why is it I said hey you know there's
something cool but I guess you can only
give sense me that's part what we do
funnier but anyway it's a sin yeah
sin number 13 is one that I've thought
about it's like of all the things the
movie does cuz I don't hate this movie
as much cinemasins appears yeah but I
have thought that that's kind of what
makes the story unfold so easily is that
every interaction he
has with other people is a bad one yeah
like no matter who he means and that did
take me out of the film a little bit
because then it feels like it's a
universe where only bad people are
around easily yeah it's a little bit of
a forced sympathetic perspective for
Arthur but it's all in his head
it's just making up what he sees other
people as anytime there's convenience or
just something weird she's good but it's
yeah I like that joke they made about
33% of this movies in his head that's a
really good point yeah I know unreliable
narrator is a form of storytelling it is
sometimes I feel like that term is
thrown around kind of loosely nowadays
to the point where like what they said
about if he is not the real Joker but
just the person who inspired the Joker
know what's the point of watching this
like I I'd be annoyed by that yeah like
no I want to accept this as a real Joker
I know there's this whole annoying thing
about age difference
Lane is different universe this means
like negative 4 years old in this movie
so I get it still I would be like well
come on if he is just a guy who inspired
the Joker then make that clear yeah yeah
yeah and I don't know maybe throw in one
other nice character who's not the
little person guy like my mom was nice
except for all the messed up things she
did yeah eventually she hurts him again
but then some of the like their nitpick
ones I really enjoyed like their number
26 about him going into male there's a
Katy's around there a lot of times I fed
the production design in the way Todd
Phillips chose to capture this from work
with his team was more built around
symbolism and to be honest we give
directors a whole bunch of Nolan
especially I think it's like it's a pass
on a lot of things because a lot of what
they're pointing out I'm like hey that's
a great point but I don't notice it in
the moment and I feel like most people
don't notice it in the moment and it's
in the aesthetic and the reason why a
lot of us don't notice it is because
they are doing a good job at the
storytelling to be plain and simple
but this is a great point of like why is
there a cage here it's not closed by the
time it is a visual metaphor for the
fact that Arthur's inward and outward
communications are trapped in a cage
that's what I'm honestly sarcastically
know you took with that thank you yeah
that's why you throw Everest
Yury out as a joke and if it sounds
plausible then you're not joking I do
gotta say I I know people will give me a
lot of crap for this it's something I
did feel like I thought Robert De Niro
was committed I thought he showed up for
this movie but I don't buy him in this
role I don't like there's nothing about
him that reads like a comedian which is
kind of strange because I mean yeah he's
a lot older now he has some one of the
greatest actors of all time King of
Comedy what he does that big speech on
the on the show for the Jerry Lewis show
he seems very believable you see why he
was working so hard to get on that show
cuz he seems like he really mastered it
but in terms of this host it's more like
I like Robert De Niro so I like him and
I also like the idea that he's doing the
Jerry Lewis role like that's neat but in
terms of just the performance in it of
itself I think he does a good job in the
serious finale interview part before
everytime we're checking in with him
like I just don't buy him as well that's
a night show like host I don't yeah it's
I buy him more as like a Charlie Rose
type where it's like you know yeah it's
a talk show but we're gonna sit down and
do a roundtable and it's not based on
being amusing and funny because yeah
he's not very loose in this role as much
as he's not really charismatic yeah yeah
and if you knocked me out you got extra
credit
sometimes good sins when I feel like
they're actually giving compliments to
reanalysis points which is kind of weird
to me when they're talking about the
height of subtlety in the movie where
they play the song everybody plays the
fool when he's accepting a gun from a
co-worker who subtly makes fun of him I
don't really have much more to say
there's a pretty big gun cuz that cinema
like what a fascinating observation
kudos to the filmmakers that that's
really awesome
I mean it's maybe unsettled that I
didn't really super notice oh yeah I
think it's well they look they were
saying it's subtle I think they mean
it's really on the nose oh yeah they're
saying it's not subtle at all what oh
come on oh yeah I didn't notice at the
time this looks like yeah I didn't know
it's at the time either just cuz you
know this song I mean well do you notice
it I gotta ask that like cinemasins team
did you notice it the first time you
watch the movie did you pick it out and
go oh your dad yeah yeah
get it feel every detail I got the move
I got a challenge that yeah I do always
wonder why he never even mentions to his
boss that like people stole the sign and
kicked his ass or something like that
because even if he's not like the
greatest employee still that's I feel
like you would just want to tell your
employer and you maybe could keep your
job yeah but it's almost the whole thing
with the bullets when he shoots the
people on the train songs had first
office for that out there liable and
attend there's a mistake
but this is something that I've heard a
lot of people point out I personally
didn't notice it the first time I
watched it I did when I got out there
was when he fired the last one I was
like wait a minute how big is the
chamber on this gun and that's something
that gets lost in movies a lot I think
is yeah any time you have a gun like
that that's something adipic all that
like I feel like if you just pay close
enough attention but I every honey
bullet room and gun like that six I
think typically well let me check my
closet there's so many okay so I
actually think the number 56 one having
named the club pogos is neat because the
declare me yeah you gonna write the
Gotham comedy club is a real comedy club
and every time you hear a Gotham comedy
club you think of that and it would've
been cool real-life Easter Egg yeah that
would have been really neat but it's got
them comedy cut because this is the
background of Chicago is Gotham's New
York and right now the comedy club
fictional city takes a little bit of New
York with the Chicago cities you know I
will say about the Bruce Wayne moment
which is something that we've definitely
harped on yeah I don't agree it's honest
it it's awesome
right yeah there he goes all is that
like a Bruce Wayne saying there's it's
ridiculous Wendy who Arthur's putting
his thumbs in his mouth but a lot of
people criticize Alfred with the fact
that he has a military background you're
like how was the guy who missed I
recommend doing this the thing that I'll
say is not every Alfred portrayal in the
history of Batman has that in his DNA
Michael goth dude he killed
and in this movie there's no specific
mention at all that that is in his
background so for all we know this
version of Alfred might not have it
maybe as a background as a [ __ ] that
being said it's still kind of surprising
that even if he's just regular Butler
caretaker that he wasn't serving this
scene oh yeah
and not able to you know get Arthur away
yeah like he's got the advantage there
Lhasa and I like what cinemasins did
bring up with Murray's talk show
featuring the Arthur Floyd comedy
footage like a lot of people even when
we saw the trailers we're like wait how
is this footage out here that we've all
pointed that out but the the idea of
like as I watch it a lot of the talk
shows I may be doing watching a talk
shows in the 80s but it does seem kind
of odd to just randomly have this
footage of a performer at an open mic in
the middle of a monologue and or at the
end of a monologue like the closer to
your monologue show especially when like
horrible open mics comedians bombing on
stages it's a normal regular weekend
thing granted it's like absurd and out
of the norm of how he bombs I just
appreciated that they pointed this out I
loved everything cinemasins pointed out
with the entire theatre experience yes
yeah like and just everything everyone
having the clown masks I thought was
really funny because I didn't bother to
question that to Party City maybe Gotham
this is the only mask they have only
masks they have but even like Arthur
breaking in there and I did think of
that when he was the usher of house no
one really noticing this why are all the
lights on yeah and what do you but the
main thing that I felt it was a nitpick
on my end but it's something that I
would totally be bothered by in real
life was when he is walking down the
stairs and he's just stand there um I
would be annoyed just seen that yeah
I've been like you're blocking my view
you're obscure maybe or you're
distracting my peripheral like one of
the [ __ ] and got them that seriously
I would I agree with that but also the
whole convenient things of the bathroom
but it's all set yeah one detail
unreliable there we go is it I gotta say
though a lot of people criticize the
whole
with tzatzi beats being in his head and
then the movie really hammering at home
with what people have referred to as The
Fight Club montage 10 or saw motto I
know but it's been ruined for me well
that's how they reveal it when they do
it honestly I I can pick up on more
subtle things a lot of the time because
you know we were filming thewe Ziya
stand we have to sometimes I do like
heavy analysis on things but I
appreciated the clarity of the montage I
would I would have eventually picked up
on it but you also understand the trying
to appeal to the masses here and even
though this is like the anti comic book
comic book movie I still think it was
the necessary visual touch and I'm not
bothered by it it's not like someone
looked to the screen and said it's all
in his head they didn't have a dialogue
about it they still managed to convey it
through a visual form so I'm cool with
it
well yeah as a viewer for me if that was
probably the plot thread I was getting
kind of annoyed by until they revealed
it and gave that little montage and I
was like oh now I get why this character
was written my way yeah I appreciate it
I'll defend that moment great point I
didn't think of was Gary and Gary call
the cops I know the custody witness is
murder
I did think it was funny how quickly he
changed into like better makeup and
cleaned up all the blood or whatever but
with Gary not reporting that to the
police to me I from a scripting
perspective I would consider that
problematic you could have even had
something just put the cops
knowing anything that's why they're
going after Arthur right now yeah I know
but it's all set and a complaint that
we've both definitely shared is the lack
of using marc maron in this movie
especially hyping it - Jackie's in it
and in cinemasins I felt really hit at
home even harder with the fact that
everything De Niro is saying to Arthur
that should have all just been given to
Marc Maron right like it's like what the
producer somebody would brief you on
who's not the hose like the host job is
just a warm-up with you yeah yeah like
hey how you doing it have develops what
type of report yeah but for a show like
that like Network big know it would have
been Marc Maron's job to communicate
least Marc Maron's job
he's gotta let you know that he's
serious and these yeah show exactly
exactly and and I'm like well you could
have made Marc Maron's they're a little
bit more permanent if you if you just
gave didn't hear who's half at least
happened to heroes lives in that moment
is Tim Eric Marin it's right now he's
just there maybe they thought DeNiro
didn't have enough line so they gave
some errands lines to De Niro
that he wound up in those two shots yeah
either way guys what do you think of
this cinemasins video are you part of
the like or dislike section do you take
them seriously do you get mad at them
what do you agree with them on this sin
count up did they point at anything that
you had not noticed before comment below
it's a lot of questions answer all them
is it all in your head subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification be
like a notify Mary we got a video up get
accepted in the reject army irony it's
all in Arthur's head Scuba Steve Scuba
Steve we had mentioned many times being
a horror fan main thing though is this
guy loves to do graffiti artwork and he
is great at it not great enough
apparently they'll tell you why I'm
currently on a jury duty trial and boy
did I try to get out of that thing by
using whatever facts I could those
lawyers really picked up on it and one
of the things I said in terms of crime I
was like well I know someone who kind of
participates in vandalism he lives in
New York graffiti artists they didn't
care
nope you're the perfect person to be on
this trial we can sense your lack of
enthusiasm so Scuba Steve I'm gonna ask
you to do more harsh crimes in case I
get called it I'm already summoned for
federal jury this she's commits worst
crime so I can use you as a way to be
like you know I know a guy who's like
really heavily involved in criminal
activities friend Steve from the noise
support him and I support him he
supports me I'd just be biased on this
case because I'm gonna vote for the
criminal this is a two-way relationship
Pat has contributed to your shadow but
also is this thanks Cuba for being here
commit worse crimes because I could use
some better excuses thank you
and that was a true story I just told
you by the way